le canada on a notre système
réglementaire qui réussit à fonctionner
mais là on a évidemment le voisin côté
qui dit on va profiter du canada mais
non si vous trouvez que le système
fonctionne bien
peu importe et les mesures législatives
et les mettre en place dans votre pays
peuvent venir simplement prendre les
médicaments directement du canada bon
une réaction a reçu de l'administration
tram qui a annoncé la mise en place d'un
système qui pourrait permettre aux
américains de se procurer légalement des
médicaments d'ordonnancé qui sont moins
chers ici au canada
une mesure qui soulève plusieurs
questions on en parle avec bertrand va
reculer le président de l'ordre des
pharmaciens du québec ont joué sur götze
bon jour là le gouvernement canadien
faudrait quand même pas été consulté la
halle avance concernant ce projet cette
annonce qui a été fait du côté des états
unis n'a jamais
discuter donc les américains n'ont pas
discuté avec ottawa
est ce qu'on doit s'inquiéter d'abord de
cette annonce faite du côté des effets
sera à court terme non dans le sens où
les compagnies pharmaceutiques qui sont
présentes au canada sont souvent des
filiales américaines ou européennes
peuvent seulement distribué au canada
on a des grossistes canadiens qui
vendent des pharmacies canadiennes et
québécoises qui vendent à des patients
d'ici alors c'est en dc où les pharmas
dessine également vendent à des patients
américains que qui sera en visite un
touriste qui aurait un problème car
oublie ses médicaments bien sûr on
laissera pas sans médicaments mais mais
de vendre en gros à des patients
américains qui débarque d'autobus
c'est pas notre travail notre travail
c'est de servir les gens d'ici de les
conseiller de suivre leur médication
maintenant faut être vigilant quand même
parce que
certains pourraient profiter de cette
situation là les pharmaciens seront
surveillés ils / elles le sont toujours
à ce niveau là et il faut s'assurer que
les fabricants locaux et les grossistes
assure l'approvisionnement local de bas
on ressent que des voyages d'américains
qui débarque un autre bus pour venir
dans nos pharmacies
reste qu' il y en a qui pourrait quand
même faire le voyage en voiture venir
acheter des médicaments
est ce que on doit cren pour certaine
pénurie parce qu'il ya des des gens de
l'industrie qui ont dit écoutez on est
pas on a déjà de la misère avec certains
médicaments à répondre aux besoins ici
des canadiens mais aussi des américains
viennent en plus
est ce qu'il ya une pénurie possible
dans certains coins faute vigilant parce
qu'on a déjà des pénuries de médicaments
pour plusieurs produits vous savez nous
les pharmaciens cela fait de nombreuses
années qu'on travaille à essayer de
réduire l'impact de ces pénuries l'on
est rendu mains des experts à jongler
avec ce temps en milieu hospitalier
qu'en milieu communautaire
mais c'est ce que si les américains
décident d'entrer au canada puis de
dévaliser nos pharmacies on va avoir des
problèmes
donc il faut vraiment être vigilant
servir les gens d'abord d'ici s'assurer
que nos grossistes ont des inventaires
et les moniteurs et ça de près et avisé
en cas de problème mais je pense qu'on
assiste présentement une période pré
électorale américaine ou alors c'est
peut-être que c'est un jeu politique est
est ce que des médicaments en
particulier qui vous viennent en tête là
quelques-uns qui serait particulièrement
intéressant à faire pour les américains
et qui pourrait les médicaments qui sont
coûteuses chez eux et qu'ils sont moins
coûteux ici donc on parle de médicaments
souvent injectable à la maison comme
comme l'insuline pendant le vu
dernièrement l'acteur mais je suis
d'ailleurs qui évolue dicaments pour les
maladie de crohn et la colite tout c'est
un roc sont moins chers ici donc il faut
offrir virginia sur ces produits là et
nous le serons assurément mais bon hein
dites nous comment on explique cette
importante différence de prix pour les
mêmes médicaments des états unis qu'à
nice et à ses symboles canadore on
réglemente les prix aux états unis on
laisse le libre marché aux états unis il
ya beaucoup de gens qui payent le
médicament pas si cher que ça parce que
ils font partie de mutuelles sont
assurés par des grandes compagnies
d'assurance et ils ont les prix beaucoup
plus bas
pour monsieur madame tout le monde aux
états unis qui n'ont pas d'assurance est
très problématique alors qu'au canada un
système beaucoup plus égalitaire
donc ce sont les pharmaceutiques elle
même aux états unis qui établissent les
prix absolument borg
parce que vous attendez même si bon on
peut penser que c'est un jeu politique
ce que vous attendez avec cette ce
risque et des américains qui viennent
acheter des médicaments moins chers ici
au canada que les pharmaceutiques a
juste un peu leurs prix aux états unis
ce serait temporel évidemment mais on a
quand même un contrôle assez strict des
prix tant au niveau fédéral avec le
conseil d'examen des prix des
médicaments brevetés ou au provincial
avec la ramq qui surveille ça de façon
authentique
donc j'ai pas trop inquiet moyen long
terme donc au s'inquiète pas tout de
suite pour garder un oeil sur la
situation
voilà on comprend que même si ottawa pas
été consulté il ya le cabinet de la
ministre fédérale de la santé
ginette petits pots terreur qui a dit
donc veiller à ce que les canadiens ne
soient protégés contre eux prend
surveille la situation là-bas également
bien monsieur bolduc merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin on va
continuer de suivre ce dossier on verra
ça va se concrétiser ou non ça restera
une promesse électorale mais je les ai